غير مؤاتيه لهم
لان الخسائر كما نسميها قد تكون خسائر
صحيه
او خسائر نهائيه
وعاده قد اخطا الان
تكون الخسائر النهائيه بين 25 وثلاثين
بالمئه اما عندهم فنحو خمسين بالمئه هذا
اولا وثانيا اذا اخذنا الخسائر النهائيه
واضح ان الجانب المدافع
خسائر اقل ولكن التناسب عشره الى واحد
لصالحنا
الخسائرنا عشر خسائر القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ما يخص المدرعات
فقد خسروا خلال هذه الفتره اكثر من 160
دبابه
واكثر من
360 مصفحه من جميع الالواح
هذا ما نراه كما ان هناك خسائر لم نراها
بسبب اسلحتنا عاليه الدقه وطويله الامد
الى تجمعات الاليات
اي ان خسائر اوكرانيا اعلى
وفق تقديراتي يصل هذا الى 25 او ربما 30%
من اجمالي الاليات التي وصلتهم من الخارج
تقريبا
انهم لو عدوها بصوره موضوعيه يتفقون مع
هذا لكن حسب ما رايت منه المصادر المفتوحه
الغربيه هذا تقريبا ما يقولونهم
اي الهجوم ماض
هم كما ذكرتها لكم الان
خسائر ونعمل من حيث الافراد لن
اشكرها فهذا
ليتكلم عنها وزير الدفاع اما نحن مدرعاتنا
خسرناه 54 مدرعه جزء منها يمكن تصليحه
عن
عواقب الاجتماعيه
وغيرها في هذا الاتجاه وبرايكم من هو
المسؤول عن كل هذا ويستحق العقاب وما هي
المساعده التي يمكن انتظارها من الناس في
هذه المناطق او لان الناس
المذنب معروف الطرف الاوكراني سعى الى هذا
فلن اقول لكم كلاما لست متاكدا منه بالمئه
مئه لم نلاحظ تفجيرات كبرى قبل انهيار
السد
او علق هذا ما ابلغوني عنه لكنهم كانوا
يضربون
السده بصواريخ هاي مارس بصوره منهجيه
ومتعدده ربما كان لديهم متفجرات موجوده
مسبقا او ربما اضافوا ضربه اخرى فبدا
انهيار السد لكن هذا في كل الاحوال ليس
بالمصلحتنا بسبب العواقب الوخيمه على
الاراضي التي نسيطر عليها
ساقول امرا
غريبا انه فشل هجومهم المضاد
لانه مناسب اكثر لروسيا لو هاجموا على ذلك
المحور
فبسبب هذا الطوفان لم يحدث هناك الهجوم
الاوكراني
لكن تعمل وزاره الطوارئ هناك وكذلك
العسكريون وسلطات المحليه
تحدثت منذ فتره مع
والي محافظتي خرسون ساندو
فقال
دهشت لتنسيق العمل على هذا المستوى
بالتاكيد هناك
صعوبات بعض الناس يرفضون
الاجلاء
عندنا هذا يحدث ايضا احيانا
فمثلا في نهر الينا حين كان هناك فيضان
بعض الناس كانوا جالسين على اسنازلهم
ويرفضون
المغادره خوفا على بيوتهم قد يكون هنا
اعتبار اعتبارات اخرى اي نبذل كل ما
بوسعنا
فيعملوا تعملوا وزاره الطوارئ بنشاط وكذلك
السلطات المحليه كما انضمت وزاره الصحه
لان علينا ان نقارب بكل جديه موضوع
السلامه الايكولوجيه والصحيه لان تحت
الماء هناك
مقابر الحيوانات
والمقابر البشريه وهي مشكله خطيره لكنها
قابله للحل يجب ان نضم هناك بناء على
الوزير قوات الدفاع الكيميائي
وبتضافر الجهود اعتقد انهم سيحلون جميع
المشاكل بما في ذلك تامين مياه الشرب
اليوم تحدثنا مع مرار حسن الدين
سنضطر الى اعاده
امدادات مياه الشرب وحفر ابار جديده العمل
جاري
ومع تراجع المياه
ستحلل المشاكل وفق ورودها
قضى الكثير من الماشيه وكذلك الحيوانات
البريه هذا يحتاج الى تنظيم وتنظيف
المنطقه وما يخص الناس فسيقدموا للجميع
منهم مساعدات وفق القوانين والمعايير
الروسيه هذه الشروط معروفه ومسجله في
قوانينه
وسنفعل ما نفعله لجميع مواطنيه روسيا
ولكل مسكن
يجب ان يجري تقييم
بالممتلكات المنقوله بغير المنقوله
ربما لم يكون جيدا ولكن عاده ما يطرحه
الناس
ويتوجهون الينا وحتى القارئين
ويطرحون نفس السؤال حول نشاط العدو في
ساحه المعركه وكل اسبوع هناك اخبار عن
الطائرات المسيره وغيرها والهجومات التي
تقوم بها وبالطبع فالسؤال الملح هو انه
تجاه منطقه بلاغاروس وهو كالاتي فكيف يجب
ان يكون
المساله كذلك بان المسيرات تصل الى الكريم
وتجري بنفس الوقت تجري عمليه تحرير
الدمباس
وايضا يجب اخلاء الناس من هناك فكيف يجي
هذا ممكن انت محق ايضا بالفعل بان هناك
خسائر كبيره في هذه المنطقه هم يخفونها
بالطبع هناك ولكنها خسائر جديه وكبيره
وللاسف الشديد هم يقولون باخفائها حتى على
ناسهم هناك ولكن هناك التجنيد يجري بشكل
كبير وحتى في بولندا ايضا وفيما يخص
المسيرات والزملاء ايضا يعلمون هذا الامر
فانه كان الوضع نفس الشيء في منطقه حميم
عندما كانت المسيرات تاتي وترمي بالقذائف
هناك في تلك المنطقه ولكن قد تعلموا هناك
التاقلم مع الوضع والرد عليها وسيطر على
هذه المسيرات بشكل سريع
ربما هناك هذا تصحيح
ولكن في بعض الاحيان هذا الامر يجري
بصعوبه ولكن هو امر محلول ويمكن السيطره
عليه
ومن جهتنا ايضا نحن نقوم باتخاذ القرارات
والاجراءات المطلوبه لكي
النجده المعدات اللازمه والمطلوبه للتصدي
لمثل هذه الهجومات وكقاعده فان المسيرات
التي تحدثتم عنها هي دائما مصنوعه من
المواد العصريه والخفيفه واغلبها من الخشب
حتى ربما ويمكن طبعا الكشف عنها ورؤيتها
بشكل سريع
وبالطبع سيتم فعل كل ما يجب ليس فقط في
موسكو وانما في المناطق الكبيره وايضا مدن
كبيره العمل يجري على هذا الامر ولكن كان
من المستحسن بالطبع ان يتم هذا العامل في
وقته
لفعل ما يجب لمنع ما يحدث ولكنني اعيد بان
هذه المساله محلوله وستتم حلها بالطبع
نهائيا والسيطره على هذا هذه العم ليه
المشكله طبعا موجوده
واعتقد انكم ايضا تفهمون ذلك
ولكن يجب ان نقوم بتوجيه قواتنا وعزمنا
الى حل هذه القضيه
والغائها تماما والقضاء عليها وايضا ان
نتوجه الى المسائل الاخرى الاكثر ضروره
ومنها الهجوم والتوجه للهجوم المضاده ايضا
والجاهزيه القصوى لذلك
هنا يمكننا الحديث طبعا عن تعزيز الحدود
بشكل خاص وانتم بالطبع تعملون هناك وعملتم
ورايتم ما يجري ويتم العمل على ذلك على
قدم وساق وهذه المساله ايضا
ستتم وستتم تعزيز الحدود بشكل جيد ولكن
امكانيه قصف حدودنا او اراضينا من قبل
الجهه الاوكرانيه هذا الامر يبقى قابلا
وقائما
وبالطبع من خلال فعاليه الصدا للهجومات
المضاده سيتم
مثل هذه الهجومات ولن
نسمح بذلك واما اذا ما استمرت هذه
الهجومات فاننا سنقوم بدراسه الوضع بشكل
اخر وايضا سنقوم بنشر القوات على المستوى
المطلوب التي لا يمكن لهم
بتخطي تلك المسافه والقيام بمثل هذه
الهجومات ولكن بشكل عام
فانه في منطقه بيلجارودس لا احد هناك
وهناك العاملين على الحدود القوات الحدود
موجوده ويعملون هناك
بالطبع المنطقه خاليه هذا امر ليس جيدا
بالطبع ولكن يمكننا ان نتنبا بان العدو
هناك وكان يجب ان يتم التجهيز بشكل احسن
او افضل لذلك ولكن العمل جاري على هذا
وسيتم بالفعل كما يجب
بالاستمرار
بهذا الموضوع فان وكاله العدو
الامير تعمل
ربما في اراضينا وهم ايضا لا يخفون بانهم
يقومون
التاثير على الراي العامه فان مقتل دوجنا
وغيرها من
العمليات التي حدثتها كل هذا يدل على ان
الجهاز الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه هم يقومون
او
بالعمل على عمليه استخباراتيه تخريبيه فما
هي فما هو العمل الذي يجري من جهتنا
لمواجهه هذا الامر والقضاء عليه ومنعه
بشكل تامه على سبيل المثال او بشكل تقريبي
فانا العمل المضاد او رده الفعل الجاريه
على هذه الاعمال فيجب علينا ان نقوم
بمحاربه هذا الامر ونحن نفعل ذلك بالطبع
احيانا يتم العمل على اساس
اصوات غير معروفه
العمل الجاري
ولكنني اود ان انوه الى انه
على خلاف
السلطات في اوكرانيا نحن لا يمكننا ان
نلجا الى الاساليب الارهابيه
فهناك لديهم نظام وهم يتعاملون بهذه
الطريقه الطريقه على انه النظام عليه
لديهم قائم على اساس الارهاب والعمليات
الارهابيه
فاما نحن لدينا الوضع عسكري ونحن لن نلجا
الى الاساليب الذي التي يتبعونها هم
ونحن نقوم بتوسيع عملنا لضمان الامن
والحفاظ على امن ارادينا واعتقد
اذا كل المس
ائل الاتجاه هي ايضا محلوله
وعليها
وانتم
ترون بعد العمليات التي تجري ربما ياتون
بسياره ويضعون فيها شيئا ما او قنابل اخرى
او لم يتم فحصها بشكل جيد فهذا الامر
يجري ولا احد يتصوره او يتنباؤه تجري ولكن
العمليات حفظ الامن هي جاريه
ومكثفه وكل شيء نقوم به لضمان امننا وامن
شعبنا ولمنع وصول مثل هذه المتفجرات
ولكن كل هذا مره اخرى يدل على انهم يتبعون
اسلوبا ارهابيا
في المواجهه
ويمكننا القول او ان نقول تجاه اولئك
الناس الذين لديهم اهداف ارهابيه ويتحركون
بهذا الشكل هم لا يخشون على امن غيرهم
ولا يعترفون بالوضع العسكري ربما اما
بالنسبه لنا فنحن لا نحتاج الى هذا
الاسلوب
وانا اتفق معكم في هذا الامر
في خلال
التوجيه الضربات والقاء النار طبعا ياتي
هذا الامر مباشره الى
المنازل والمباني وغيرها مناطقنا وتجري
هذه في منطقه
بريانسكورد وغيرها ولكن فهل المساعدات
التي تقدم الى هذه المناطق هي كافيه لضمان
امنهم نحن على تواصل دائم مع قيادات هذه
المناطق ونتحدث معهم
وايضا نحن على علم بما يحتاجون اليه وكل
هذا ياتي الينا ايضا
بالموثقا بالاوراق
بشكل قانوني ونحن قمنا بمناقشه العديد من
القضايا وبشكل مطول
وقد تحدثت مع السيده امارات شكرا للزيان
حول منطقه بالجرد
وربما يمكن ان اخطا او
فهناك تم تقديم نحو
مليار
او مليار و700 مليون
من المساعدات الى تلك المناطق
وانا اشكركم على انكم قد تطرقتم الى هذه
المساله
ونحن بالطبع سنستمر في هذا
العام ونساعد كل عائله ونحاول ان نؤمن لهم
كل ما يحتاجونه وهذا امر ضروري بالطبع
بالنسبه لنا
والموارد لدينا كافيه لتقديم المساعدات
وستصلهم كما يجب وفي الوقت المناسب بالطبع
السيد الرئيس
قناه روسيا في الوقت الحالي قطاع الصحه او
القطاع الطبي في
هو قد تاذى لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات